every time I'm driving my hands
immediately starts shaking and it's like
okay you're behind me I don't know for
what but I know you're behind me so
let's just pray that you don't hear
you're like
[Music]
three three one we have got fire we have
one plus take down the fan we've all
watched the horrifying footage of black
men being killed by police while on the
road oh my god please don't tell me he's
dead
and we watched black women violently
arrested for minor driving infractions
failure to signal you're doing all of
this get over there
we've seen the public reaction to police
killings but for black Americans the
story doesn't end once the news cameras
are gone we set out to hear first-hand
from everyday people what it feels like
to drive while black in America today
that journey took us to two high-profile
locations Falcon Heights Minnesota where
falando Castillo was killed and Prairie
View Texas where Sandra bland was
arrested so how would you explain to
someone you know if I'm if I were to ask
you what does it mean to drive while
black driving scared every time you get
in your vehicle you're scared
because if any cop gets behind you if
you ask any african-american our heart
to instantly drop it means to drive
around and fear it means to drive around
and also hope what's the hope hope that
we make it home safe you don't want to
think about the fact that something
could happen to you
but in the back of everyone's mind I'm
pretty sure that it's there it's always
in mind at least Lando Castile was shot
by an officer during a traffic stop
his girlfriend filmed his final moments
as he lay bleeding to death next to her
her four-year-old daughter was in the
backseat could you believe it when I saw
this at parties I could you know it was
just the extreme of saying you know when
is it going to stop but it's effective
knowing that it's happened so many times
that just it's not expected that was one
of the toughest things for me because I
have my daughter everywhere I go and I
can't imagine something happening to me
she's in the backseat how traumatized
were you seeing that video it was
another event that was real
life-changing because that's something
that now I fear for myself that before I
never feared that I didn't imagine being
shot by the police with my daughter in
the car but now when I see police in my
rearview and I'm about to be stopped my
heart races that could have been me
or it still could be me Sandra bland was
pulled over for failing to signal when
changing lanes after an argument and
arrest she was taken to County Jail
where she was later found hanged in her
cell so we're coming up right there
that's that some more that's where she
was pulled over and you drive down this
road every single day how do you feel
when you see this honestly is just fear
injustice it makes you I don't know
that's heartbreaking
that's heartbreaking and every morning
you walk or you drive by and it's like
why just why what have you had any
experiences of like being pulled over
like that yes actually um me and my
boyfriend driving winds so positively I
was doing 70 miles per hour and a 50 but
I have a cop radar and my spit um we
have a cop radar here it's right here
why why do you have that for protection
and my opinion we all need one
especially if you're african-american
college to do we all need one because
they automatically assume we're
intoxicated or we're high everywhere we
go I'm sorry
schmuck operator Oh so okay what does
that mean this means we're approaching a
cop which is probably the cop that I'm
normally telling you about and what's
going on in your head now uh speed limit
three limit to make sure everything get
hairy I know you have your seatbelt on
so we're good there and just making sure
that there's no reason for him to
possibly stop me whatsoever I have a
good friend he he puts stickies right
here so one his license is right here
and his service is right here he sticks
them on he sticks it right on the
stairwell why because he doesn't have to
reach so now that that eliminates the
thought process and feared that the
policeman might have so we're going
based off the the fear that they have
not always about what we got so it's
kind of a situation where you feel like
either you comply or you die and you
have to choose between the two just the
skin and my height I think my height
puts me in the arm disadvantageous
position as well you know I Drive a
minivan you know I try and you know
dress up and I always hope that that
will help me see another day but that
makes me really sad to hear that you
have to like wear a suit and drive your
minivan Janis now save that hope that
people give you the benefit of doubt
yeah and I wear pink and stuff like I
wear like I wear light colors yeah I
wish to show your shoes right now
they're your beauty I think how do you
think your life would be different if
you were a white dude for driving
purposes I wouldn't worry every time I
see a cop
do you feel like you're an equal citizen
under the law as an African American
absolutely not no my mom worries the
death every time she's like you know
make sure you call me when you get home
cuz she's not worried about Western
accent yeah every time I love my mother
she calls me every day and when the
Sandra bland thing happened it's like
she called me every hour on the hour
just because I'm her baby whether I'm 20
or not I'm still her baby and she wants
to make sure her baby is alive and is
okay and that is its
and you know it's sad it's sad waking up
and wondering well I make it to my
college campus so every time you get
pulled over you call your wife yeah why
because at the end of day I want I don't
want anybody telling like I'm real big
on you know preserving whatever story is
happening and I know my wife tell it
right you know I mean just her actually
hearing on what's happening it seems
like we need to ask the confirmation hey
as an african-american while we're
driving on your streets what do we need
to do in order for you not to feel
afraid because every time we get over
their justification was I was afraid for
my life
we're not that scary we bleed the same
way you bleed we cry the same way you
cried why does it have to be far to
flight for a simple traffic stop why do
we always have why do we have to live
and am I going to live or survive kind
of state and that kind of state of mind
can you imagine that I don't think most
Americans can imagine
you know who you know you know you know
who does that people in a war they live
with the mentality when they're on a
battlefield live or die why do I have to
do that driver
[Music]
you